lots to discuss with this gent um his
mmqb
column uh latest is uh just as much read
much must read material as he always
writes uh my longtime friend from nbc
from nfl network as well uh sis
albert breer back here on the rich eisen
show how are you albert
i'm good how are you doing rich how's
the uh environment i guess
you know what all right it's everything
i'm just looking around everything's
fine it's just interesting
uh chris brockman is wearing the number
one of tony franklin back in the day for
the new england patriots
uh all of a sudden he's such a big fan
of the number one from the patriots
jersey
albert it's amazing you're a big fan are
you a big fan of the number one two
like that a certain quarterback who
might be wearing number one
i couldn't be more excited i mean we've
been giving teams the number one for a
long time albertson
it's good to finally have a great number
one on the roster
well we got a number one that you did
that i think all of us can root for
right now right rich
well you know what uh who is that a
reference to
uh the guy who wears number one at the
ohio state university who's trying to
fight for
big ten football to somehow return well
yeah
i mean i think this would give you a
chance to be a fan of justin fields even
if it's only temporary
well let's let's start here first albert
because obviously
um the big ten and the pac-12 saying
we'll see you in january
um significantly effects
at the very least and when we're talking
professional football
the non-playing talent evaluation
portion of the nfl calendar so
the big ten and the um and the pac-12 as
well as whatever the sec
uh big 12 and acc decide what to do
uh impacts the nfl and will be on your
radar screen and everybody else in the
nfl information business what what are
you hearing right now is this a
possibility
that what justin fields is doing by the
way michigan wolverine parents
apparently created a twitter page today
at wolverine family just to post a
letter that they are demanding a
sit down virtually with kevin warren of
the big ten the
commissioner as well as the school
president of michigan they want answers
about what they base their decision on
is there any there there here
well i think it's interesting at the
very least you know i i haven't talked
to some people at those schools
it sure sounds like the problem isn't so
much with the decision itself
as it is with the lack of communication
um and the lack of reasoning and you
know they really felt like i
i guess the best way you can you know
put it is charlie brown with lucy
pulling the football away with the way
the schedule
came out last week um i guess two weeks
ago now
um just you know five six days in front
of the season getting cancelled and so
um you know i think you've seen it from
ohio state parents from penn state
parents from iowa parents
um nebraska parents michigan parents i
think those five schools are the ones
right now
they just want answers they want um you
know
reason why the big ten can't go forward
in the sec
the ecc and the big 12 can and there's a
lot on the line for a lot of these kids
you know and it's not just the kids who
are going to the nfl
um you know it's you know the fifth year
seniors the guys that may never play
football again
um you know and i think really that's
what i the biggest thing i think they
want is to know that their kids were a
priority in this decision
and that it wasn't just about liability
and i think above all else they want to
know that all options to play the season
in the fall were exhausted before this
move was made because i know
that there's a lot of skepticism in
those schools about that part of it they
felt like there was more that could have
been done to try to get to see the fight
to fall
well i guess you know uh with news
coming out about testing the new saliva
test that the well that the nba had been
using
with yale and it got fda approval this
past week and it's been talked about
either it's a game changer
or a game modifier depending on how you
know um
how i guess well-versed you are on all
of this and
that that i guess the the conversation
is that what the big ten
and the pac-12 did was premature unless
you
you you read up about the the apparent
health report that the school presidents
got the pac-12
uh presidents essentially told pete
famil that
uh it was it was over it was open and
shut what they heard
so what what are you what are you
hearing on that front
well i'll tell you what rich i uh before
all of this before the last six months
i i had no idea doctors disagree with
them with each other
as much as they do right it is
unbelievable like how
how how massive the disagreement can be
um i can just tell you and i'm not
you know i'm not a college football
reporter i know a lot of people
in that level of the game but i i don't
cover it day to day like somebody like
pete does
um you know what i can tell you is you
know at the nfl level it's
you know the way that they're combating
it is through you know just
i i like the constant testing of course
like in and the daily testing is an
important piece of it
you know and then following up with
heart scans with ekgs when that goes
with
all that sort of stuff so there is a
problem they'll catch it really really
really quickly
um and i think part of the issue at the
college level
has been one of resources like you know
you're michigan or ohio state or your
clemson or alabama
can afford to to put the resources
behind it to create
something close not maybe exactly like
we're coming close to what the nfl is
doing
um you know whereas you know can
say you know what minnesota do that can
say a rutgers do that
can a pit do that can a mississippi
state do that
um you know i think that's that's sort
of you know been
part of the issue at the college level
and the thing about this saliva test
that is i think really important it's a
it's how quick the result gets turned
around it's instant right
and then b how cheap it is and i saw
numbers where it's
absolute numbers where it's like four or
five dollars a test and so
i i think the accessibility and the
ability to constantly
uh test athletes that's why this is a
game changer because if you're testing
guys more consistently
because and if you can do it because
it's a little cheaper and it's more
accessible
you know well then that changes
everything because that means
you know if you're doing it every day
you're going to catch it before you put
a kid who has this heart condition out
in the field
and i will say this rich you know my
wife is a cardiac nurse
yep this is a very serious condition
myocarditis is a very serious condition
it's
not to be taken lightly um you know so i
think the risk would be
uh and it's not something you don't need
a pre the other thing you don't need a
pre-existing
condition to get it like it can it can
like hold it can
it's been proven coding can't lead to
this condition you don't need something
pre-existing for it to happen
um you know i think that the key is with
as is the case of a lot of other things
that pop up um
you know with doctors who uh deal with
football players
but the key is catching it instantly and
if you can catch it instantly that
mitigates a lot of the problem
albert breer is the mbl qb here on the
rich eisen show a couple more coveted
related
questions for you first one again just
to tie up this
uh college uh nfl um situation
for the lack of a better phrase is what
are the conversations within the nfl
offices right now about moving
the combine and moving the draft to at
least accommodate all these kids that
uh might play in january february and
march
um and also uh if the entire college
football community comes to that
conclusion eventually
right so the first thing you want to
remember the nfl wants to help college
football
college football is great for the nfl
but three real reasons for that number
one it's a free minor league
um and uh the expensive minor league the
difficulty in monetizing them minorly
the nfl is a warning part of that
so the system they have where the
players get like
world-class level coaching get developed
for three years and get delivered to
them
at 21 22 years old they don't want to
mess with that
number two the way that the players are
marketed but johnny manziel and tim
tebow say we're saying you all about
guys like that those guys were stars
when they got to the nfl
and that brings me to the third point
which is you know the the college
football really is the foundation for
the biggest
event in the nfl's offseason calendar
the draft
um if college couple the ones who's so
popular
then the draft wouldn't have this sort
of motor that it does
um with the with the public and so you
know the end of college football is
great for the nfl the nfl wants to help
college football
and so i think they're wanting to go to
a certain distance to try and help them
i know some people have been in touch
with some guys at the nfl
office and i would tell you that the
the people in college football um that
are working on this i know there's some
individual coaches in the big ten that
are working on this too
they're working on a plan that would
work for everybody if they can't play in
the fall
so you know that could be a january
february schedule
playing in dome stadiums with the nfl
combine move back and the nfl draft
moved back to
accommodate those kids so those kids
wouldn't have to choose between going to
the combine
or going to their pro day and playing
through their season
and so i can tell you the nfl is
amenable
to trying to work with college football
to get a season
and try to do what's best for all the
athletes and then there's the question
about
uh protocols in the nfl and what happens
if if somebody tests positive
um or two right let's just say
something that that has uh
struck or stricken the miami marlins and
the st
louis cardinals happens in the nfl wha
what is the plan for that right now
albert so the one thing they've talked
about is kind of forming a committee
um that you know would report to roger
goodell
um of people who maybe aren't connected
with teams so obviously take any
competitive issues out of it
um that would make those sorts of
decisions i i can tell you
like a lot of teams wanted hard and fast
wanted some hard and fast standards like
you know okay
like we have x number of players that
get it that constitutes an outbreak
and x number of players get it that
you know necessitates a forfeiture um or
this percentage of the position group
goes down here's the protocol for how
you go
through that you know that's what nfl
teams were really looking for ahead of
training camp and they didn't get it
and my sense is one of the reasons why
is so much has changed
over the last six seven eight weeks um i
i can't speak for you rich but
you know i i like i thought at the
beginning of june we'd be in a much
better spot than we are
you're nationwide with the virus no
doubt so you know i think there's like
an acknowledgement there
that things are going to keep changing
and what makes sense as far as a hard
and fast rule in the middle of
august might not make sense in the
middle of october
so i do know the one thing that they
have discussed i think this is probably
the likely route they go is try to find
a way to come come up with a committee
and whether it's six people eight people
10 people put some medical people on
there put some people have some
experience with teams on there
where you know that committee would work
with roger
to you know be sort of that you know
emergency
you know that that that group that deals
with the emergency situations where
if you do have an outbreak right before
a game there
there are some people that you can that
you go to that'll sort of make the big
hard decisions on on what to do about it
so basically like we'll form a committee
to deal with the hard decisions
uh when we need to but right now there's
no
going into the season x number of
players here
this is what we're going to happen we're
going to cancel the game and
there's just no hard and fast rule is
essentially what you're saying right now
right now i mean right i mean that could
change over the next few weeks you know
like i said this thing's been changing
so
fast it's not i think i mean like the
nfl like that but that's the thing is
like you know and you know the ladies
you know
you know a ton of these people rich you
know the way they they they want it they
they want to know the rules beforehand
you know what i mean like they want to
know
like okay like so if this is what it is
this is what it is
and we'll deal with that and i just
think that you know
things have changed so quickly and
things have evolved over the night over
the last
few months um to the point where i i do
think the nfl wants to maintain some
level of flexibility so i'm not saying
they couldn't put in something they
still have
um you know three weeks before we're
even into
the into the the practices towards week
one you know what i mean towards that
game week
um yeah but as of right now i it feels
to me at least like they may be
leaning more towards that committee
approach and do you have you heard of
any teams that have basically said
um hey we're
anybody that goes out at night um has to
face the music within
our four walls uh do you know anybody
that's basically
or have all coaches kind of given the
speech that coaches give to players
before they go on bye weeks
saying don't do anything that stupid
essentially i mean
have you heard that yeah i mean i know
they've used examples from other sports
um you know i think what happened in
oklahoma was probably a good example too
right like if you look at um you know
and i think lincoln riley's done as good
job as anybody
but he gave the players a week off and
you know they come back and they had
zero positive tests i think they had a
round of tests where they tested
150 people had zero positives and they
come back from that week off and all of
a sudden they've got nine positives you
know
and um and that's a program again that
that has done
i think just about everything right when
it comes to this
that sort of illustrates the list of the
the the risks out there obviously you
get the
example of the marlins everybody saw
sean mcveigh use that on hard knocks
last week
um and i i do know that the message from
him
every coach i've talked to at the
beginning of camp was
listen you know whoever is the most
responsible team
is going to be one of the teams that's
standing at the end and we have a chance
to give ourselves a competitive
advantage here
if we're responsible about it and so i
think everybody has gotten that message
and had that drilled home
over and over and over again over the
first couple of weeks of camp
there's a part that part of this rich
though that you know
is going to be sort of variable
that they can't control which is what
happens when those
kids go back to school in a couple weeks
what happens when people's wives go back
to work
um there is a piece of this of course
that i don't think anybody
is going to be able to control that it's
just going to be sort of introduced as
again kids start going back to school
people start going back to warren
because they're not in a bubble
all right so i got time for one football
question we might as well bring it full
circle
um cam newton's a starter right in new
england i mean the whole conversation
about
um that he's a hard-working kid and
we're hearing
we're hearing everything out of new
england about how stidhum was this and
hoyer's that um it's cam's gig
right i mean this is it we're gonna see
we're gonna see cam out there week one
it's gonna be belichick hooking up with
cam as opposed tom brady uh hors
d'oeuvre
for us to all feast on all year long
right
yeah yeah and you know i'll give you an
interesting anecdote from 2011.
um i i you know i i had a couple people
i was talking to who used to work there
who were there
in 2011 who you know talked about
bill's message coming out of the lockout
and because of
like the weirdness of that season and
the lack of a ramp up
you know what bill kept saying to the
guys and they went to the super bowl
that year was
you don't want to be the team that's
going to be you know that that's not
going to be properly conditioned
uh because that team is going to get run
over right
when the real games start well what
better
way to deal with a dynamic like that
than to throw a 270 pound quarterback at
people
um i thought it was a really interesting
way to look at it
i think just for the circumstance of
this year
i think camden a lot it is in a lot of
ways perfect
for the patriots no one knows what
they're going to be running offensively
at you
they're going to have the ability to be
creative there's some simple stuff they
can put in
that that guys are going to be able to
adapt to really quickly
and so i think you know bill signing cam
was very much with 2020 in mind knowing
that he might be the ideal quarterback
for these circumstances
and you know the upshot of it is rich if
he is who he was three or four years ago
well then you get to resign them and
maybe you have your tom brady
replacement so
good for 2020 and also with potential to
be to be good for more than that so
exciting albert
it really really it really is oh yeah so
i'll leave you with a
sports talk radio question uh who who's
got the biggest chip
on his shoulder is it uh brady or or cam
oh
great question how about how about how
about bill wanting to show everybody
that he could win without tom and then
it wasn't just uh
how about that for an answer if you want
to get the sports right here sure
i mean you could throw bill in there too
he will never admit that there's a
shoulder
or a chip or a chip potatoes
or a potato chip or a poker chip there's
no chips
there's no chips i mean not even in his
subway sandwiches
that he's hawking i think i think bill i
think though i i i
he won't he'll never admit this but i
think bill belichick will be
paying special attention to the nfc
south standings this phone i'll put it
that way
this is so great oh i've been asked i i
don't know the answer to this question
and i very very rarely ask questions i
don't really know the answer to i've
just been uh
don bowie uh my ep just got in my ear
say
ask him about his instagram oh there it
is your instagram photo
very nice you're probably avatar look at
you looking all nantucket tanned and
rested sitting in our guest chair
all smiley albert look at that i every
time i come in the studio i've got like
i've just got
an electric can going on you do very
george hamilton yeah yeah you guys are
giving me a good opportunity to get
look at that lighting next time we just
got to make sure that we just twist the
mug a little bit more because the
you know our show logo is somewhat
obscured but we'll just handle it
we'll handle it thank you though i will
say this though rich i think
i think maybe the best picture i ever
took like just as far as tanning goes
and everything else
may have been with you but not in that
studio actually on island it was in
nantucket where we we watched i forget
was it was it france versus croatia was
that the world cup match we watched that
yeah
it was at the gazebo gazebo on the long
wharf there in the great city of
nantucket i got a great picture of me
and albert at the directv party in
phoenix one year
oh yeah don't show anybody that yeah by
the way
this is this is not usually a before i
uh i hit you with this out the door but
i i will do it nonetheless
in the few moments we have remaining
tell me about uh jason wright
the new team president of the washington
football team
yeah i mean i like look you know
mckenzie's obviously been
uh you know a firm that the nfl's been
close with you guys may know
uh brittany bowling who's been groomed
to sort of
take pat ball his old chair um as the as
the principal owner of the broncos
she went through um the program there
and so
you know it's he's somebody the nfl has
uh
had an eye on for a while um and i
i think what's really interesting about
it obviously was the diversity end of it
which is great you know that we have
somebody
uh you know a team president royals
caller for the first time
i i also think the fact that he's young
is gonna be really interesting you know
he's 38 years old he played in a wii
u and the team is going through this
just massive rebrand
and so uh you know i think having
somebody with that sort of fresh
perspective
and a different outlook on things is
going to be really really good and then
you know i
i've asked around a little this morning
um it does sound like when he was
see when he was playing in the league
you know people
i i think people knew that that guy over
there
yeah he's got something coming after
he's done playing that's probably going
to be a lot better than what he's doing
right now which you know obviously
has wound up being the case yes seven
years in the league uh and now
the first uh person of color to be a
team president
in the national football league and uh
for the washington football team
to boot uh albert thank you for the time
appreciate it good to chat with you
let's chat with you uh real soon best
your wife and your family
you too rich and uh if you want me to
send you that justin fields jersey i'll
get it in the mail right away
you know what um you know what senator
i think i have too many ohio state uh
trinkets around here from uh
from from past uh november's uh paying
things off
uh but i will accept anything from you
albert especially phone calls these days
thanks for the call brother
i'll be right on it all right you got it
that's albert breer hey bud hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here